anthony même bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors est
ce que est ce une victoire qui pourra
faire office de précédent pour le fisc
français
en effet c'est un précédent qui fera
office de deux dates en effet c'est la
première fois que le fisc obtient de
facebook des pénalités pour ne pas avoir
déclaré ses impôts en france en effet
facebook faisait remonter tous ces
bénéfices perçus par ces publicités en
france et les revenus générés par son
activité en france en irlande là où
était son siège social tout en sachant
que l'irlande elle même fait remonter au
delà were aux états unis l'ensemble de
ses bénéfices et ce qui permet en
réalité à la holding de facebook de
payer le moins d'impôt en bénéficiant
par voie d'un dumping fiscal d'un d'un
choix là où la fiscalité la moins
importante du choix du pays dans lequel
elle fera remonter tous ses revenus et
c'est la première fois que la france
fonctionne 106 millions d'euros on a
l'impression que c'est une somme
relativement importante
en réalité on est loin du compte on est
loin du compte lorsque l'on sait que
facebook pourrait générer des bénéfices
de 500 millions d'euros par an en france
et que donc la peau de son revenu serait
de 150 millions par an et on se rend
compte que 106 millions la pénalité est
temps que de 22 millions on est loin du
compte par rapport aux centaines de
d'euros d'impôts que facebook aurait dû
payer tout en sachant qu'il s'agit d'une
amende qui a trait à la période 2009 à
donc on voit qu'en réalité c'est une
bonne affaire pour facebook
comment justement comment comment
comprendre que le fisc français n'aille
pas jusqu'au bout finalement et se
contente d'un accord ou facebook france
bat finalement payet - comme vous venez
de nous l'expliquer alors il est curieux
que le fisc français est acceptée cette
amende à 100 6 millions lorsque google
elle a été condamnée à 1 milliard il y a
peu de temps donc on voit une disparité
entre facebook et google certainement
parce que les revenus générés sont
sensiblement différent et on explique la
petitesse de cette somme par le fait
qu'en réalité le fils n'a pas la main
min sur les chiffres générés en france
ni sur les revenus remonter en y allant
des eaux de lower facebook est une
société privée qui a le libre choix de
ceux domiciliés fiscalement dans l'état
dans lequel l'estimera que son revenu
sera le moins taxés et c'est ce qu'elle
fait librement
il faut pas oublier que l'évasion
fiscale n'est pas un délit c'est à une
possibilité cuse et dont abusent les
gaffes allaient tous les grands du web
l'utilisent pour justement faire
remonter tous les revenus générés dans
un état dans l'état où elle sera le
moins taxés alors en juillet dernier la
justice européenne a annulé la décision
de la commission européenne contre apple
cette fois 13 milliards d'euros que la
marque à la pomme ne remboursera pas à
l'irlande l'irlande qui s'en félicite
alors pourquoi de temps de désaccord
concernant les impôts payés par les gars
femmes dans l'union européenne
européenne quand on était auraient été
tous ces litiges proviennent par
l'absence de
alimentation il ne faut pas oublier que
le web les réseaux sociaux les gaffes à
ont une ancienneté relativement récentes
puisqu'elles n'ont que 10 en réalité
facebook n'est que dix ans donc on voit
où 15 ans et que c'est un une section
des nouvelles technologies et on voit
que le droit dans les nouvelles
technologies mais du temps pour les
réglementer et la difficulté du web par
rapport à ces nouvelles technologies
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de frontières on
est dans l'international le plus complet
et au niveau international les très dur
de réglementer voire impossible car il
n'existe pas de juridiction
supranationale
merci beaucoup anthony même d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes avocat spécialiste du monde
numérique